happy pride i wish i could say that this  is the kickoff to a whole bunch of lgbtq  plus focus  videos you know really big projects that  i've been putting a lot of work into but  it's  just not um getting my novel ready for  publication really did take a lot of  time and i wasn't able to pull something  like that together but i will be  dropping these sorts of videos  short little succinct things on specific  elements of lgbtq plus  history or general knowledge and why  don't we start with  why do we have pride month in june well  the reason is is that  june was when the stonewall riots took  place in 1969  in new york and that is generally  considered  the beginning of what was at the time  called the gay liberation movement  later to encompass the entire lgbtq plus  spectrum  president clinton was the first  president to acknowledge june as a  celebration  though he called it gay and lesbian  pride president obama would later say  that it was lgbtq  pride month